[Music]
the Galileo probe orbited Jupiter for
years looking at the cloud tops of the
planet and the moons that orbit it but
at the end of the mission they decided
they could do one more scientific
experiment December 7 1995 NASA's
Galileo spacecraft drops a 750-pound
titanium probe into Jupiter's atmosphere
it slams into the cloud tops at over
106,000 miles an hour
[Music]
even though Jupiter looks calm and
serene from a distance as you get closer
you realize that there are ferocious
winds there are lightning storms and
there are pressures that would crush any
instrument the planet is a thousand
times the mass of the earth and that
means as your inward the pressures and
densities become very large the probe
sensors reveal that hydrogen makes up
90% of Jupiter's atmosphere temperatures
soar to over 300 degrees
winds rage at 400 miles an hour
it's hotter and more turbulent than
scientists ever imagined
58 minutes after entering Jupiter's
atmosphere and just 95 miles down the
probe vaporizes leaving most of
Jupiter's secrets beyond our reach